good evening councillors
um welcome to the tonight's
performance governance and audit meeting
held on thursday the 29th of july 2021
my name is councillor jeanette stiltz
and i am the chair of this committee
before we commence business of this
meeting there are a few housekeeping
rules to run through
members the setup for the meeting has
been signed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
within the protocols
agreed at council on the 29th of april
2021
in the interest of member and officer
safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hands
up or raise your paddle to indicate you
will wish
to speak then i will invite you at the
appropriate time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask
put on your visor turn on your
microphone and speak
clearly please reference a page
or paragraph number when referring to
the agenda papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise
as possible and ensure your microphones
remain
off when not speaking
can i also call
the safe your um sorry
can i also call your attention to the
safety
of the building the fire exit is behind
me
and to please remember that the floors
here are on different levels when
walking around the chamber
berna do we have any apologies
for absence thank you chairman yes we've
received apologies for absence from
councillors boyce and jarvis
thank you thank you item three on your
agenda is the minutes
of the meeting held on the 10th of june
2021
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting
held on the 21st
on the 10th of june 2021 and found on
pages
5 to 14 are approved as a true and
accurate record
so i move do i have a seconder thanking
councillor none
members do you wish to agree those
minutes by a cent
or move to a vote thank you
item four on the agenda is declarations
of interest
members it's to disclose the existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
related to items of business on the
agenda have in regards to paragraph
6 to 8 inclusive of the code of conduct
for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if
any member has an interest to declare
please use the hand
or please put your hand up and use your
paddle and i will invite you to speak
so do i have any declarations of
interest
councillor fleming thank you chair um as
a member of essex county council
any item for turning a non-pecuniary
thank you thank you council training any
other items of declarations of interest
no thank you item 5
public participation i can advise that
we have not received
any submissions from members of the
public
item six on the agenda is
the report the internal auditor's report
progressor revolt affordable housing and
housing needs
audit knowledge management audit and
follow-up of recommendations found on
pages
15 to 56
i call upon mr rubins
to present report thank you mr rubens
thank you very much and it's good to be
back in person even though
perhaps not quite in normal
circumstances but i'm sure we'll get
there
there's quite a few reports as part of
this
item there's four reports in total so
i'll take you through each of those
in turn and obviously there'll be time
for questions
at the end so the first report is our
progress report and i'm talking to page
18 here of your pack
so you'll see we've got two reports that
i'll present
this evening on knowledge management and
housing needs
and then there's one further piece of
work from last year which is the fraud
risk assessment which will be presented
to the next meeting we've done the work
we've produced a report and we're just
agreeing that with officers
at the moment so that one will will be
at the next meeting
and then there's a number of pieces of
work underway in the 21-22 plan
one other thing just to point out um is
you'll see that we've
moved one of the audits for this year uh
climate change and sustainability to the
22
23 year and that's to give time to allow
the sustainability strategy and plan
to be developed and then obviously that
will give us something toward it
in that year so if i now
talk to um the first of the two reports
that we're
presenting in terms of audits that we've
completed
the affordable housing and housing needs
report and
that starts on page 23 of your pack
and i'll talk to sort of page 26 which
is the sort of key findings from that
piece of work so overall we've given
moderate assurance for the design of
controls and the effectiveness of
controls
and on the whole we found good processes
in place for
um putting together a strategy and
identifying your housing needs
um but the key issue and you'll see
we've we've raised this as a high
priority
issue on on page 28 is that the council
has not been meeting its targets
around housing development
we did think quite carefully about this
one is does that actually create a
limited
opinion report but we've we've given you
i suppose the benefit of the doubt and
that actually if you look at the numbers
uh the council is quite slow to start
within in developing this housing but it
has increased
uh its pace um and if you take the last
two years together it's more or less
been on target but there's clearly still
work to be done around that um we've
also raised an issue about the housing
strategy board
not meeting and that's going to be put
back together
so um and also around commuted funds the
section 106 money is needing a strategy
for how you spend those so a number of
issues
raised in that report and we've had some
positive responses
from officers to that and clearly you
know
there has been an impact of covid uh
on on the on the perhaps the speed of
which some of these things
have been done but there's work to be
done there
the third report in this batch of four
is the
knowledge management report which starts
on
page 37 of your pack and again i'll talk
to the key findings on page 40.
so again this is a moderate assurance
for design and effectiveness
we found on the whole the council's got
good processes
in terms of identifying efficiency
documenting those
uh getting staff involved and getting
the ownership of that and you know
that's been i think
on the whole a good process the key
issues that we've raised are around
documenting the prioritization process
uh as to you know what what areas you
look at first
um and i think also on the business
continuity plan we found that was out of
date
so since the council has been
reorganized you need to update your
business continuity plan in terms of the
key offices in that plan and obviously
that's important
that people know who to turn to if there
is an issue there
and then the fourth of these reports
which is on
starts on page 49
is the follow-up of previous
recommendations um
and we've been able to sign off three
recommendations
with two overdue one of those relates to
building control
which is a high priority but the council
has uh recruited someone now to
deal with that issue and we're expecting
that one to be dealt with by the end of
september
uh hopefully we can sign that one off
next time
the other thing just to point out we
mentioned on page 52
is the safeguarding report you'll know
there were some issues there that
members were concerned about
we haven't followed that up yet because
the due dates for when those
recommendations are supposed to be
implemented hasn't been reached yet
but i understand from officers that
there has been progress on that
and obviously officers can update you uh
if you require
so that's quite a lot of to go through
but i'm very happy to take
questions before you take the questions
can i move the recommendations the
recommendations found on page 15 of the
report are
litter one internal audit report
appendix 21 that the committee
comment considers comments and approves
little one
the audit internal audit process report
july 2021 appendix one little two the
affordable housing and housing needs
audit
july 2021 appendix 2
the knowledge management and audit june
2021 appendix 3 and the follow-up of
recommendations
report march 21 at appendix 4. can i
have a seconder for these
recommendations thank you councillor
none
so i will now open the debate councillor
none
yes sir thank you very much chair and
thank you mr rubins for
your report could i go to
appendix 2 please affordable housing
um given the criteria
mr rubin's for the color coding
i found red to be quite harsh
in this report given that you've
acknowledged the difficulties through
covid but unless i've misread page 28
this council over delivered
its affordable housing over two
successive years
also you've said that um
you've had officer responses to some of
the queries
and i wonder really whether they have
been included in this report
thank you thank you mr evans
so um well it's interesting that
perspective because
we've had other queries from members
saying perhaps we've been too lenient on
the council on this so i don't know
maybe that means we've got it right but
if you look at page 28 you're right
there are two years where the council
has exceeded its targets but not they're
not successive years so 2021 for example
68 delivery rate um so below the 100
um that you need so an overall 49
delivery rate so i would say for you
know such a key target
you know i do think that that is a high
priority uh and it's important to see
and that consistently met each year um
we did we do have responses from
officers so if you look for example at
the bottom of page 29
there is a management response there and
it says that each of the
recommendations are going to be met
either in september or december of 21
and there will be member oversight of
that so as i said i think we've had a
reasonable management response to
those issues could i come back please
you can um so thank you for that mr
rumors um
i'm not sure which members have said
that
this is lenient because i thought it was
subject to this committee's
scrutiny but
thank you for your response to that i am
however very concerned
about the building control
element and how that's in red and that
that does concern me greatly
as far as development in this within
this
district council is concerned
yeah so my comment was relating to we
have a pre-meeting with members before
uh with the
you know the chair and the vice chair
before and i don't think they were
saying it was linkedin but they were
saying why did we
you know go down that that side of
moderate um
so um that that was that i agree with
you about the building control it's a
high priority
needs to be addressed but as i said
there is recruitment of someone to deal
with those issues and we are expecting
it to be
implemented next time thank you mr
rivers thank you chair
thank you council
oh mr leslie did you want to come back
before i go on to your
councils yeah thank you just to provide
some more information around the
building control
obviously with outline the reasons in
terms of resourcing it hasn't been
delivered to date
uh mr rubin's has obviously confirmed
that there's uh additional
resource in post temporarily now to
specifically address that audit
requirement the latest
update is the work is nearly completed
and it is on track at the moment to
be done by the september deadline that's
currently being given
thank you councillor herder so you've
got your hand up and i see you've got
your hand up councillor hull councillor
heard um thank you chairman
um can i just take you to page 20 please
and uh perhaps mr rubens can help me
through you chair
climate change and sustainability are
they two
separate audits
no that would be one audit okay the
reason the reason i ask is that uh
obviously climate change is very much in
the current uh
in the news currently uh and i'm
wondering why that one has been
i appreciate you touched upon it so far
but why that one
in particular has been moved to 2223
uh whereas policy review perhaps maybe
didn't seem to me to be so urgent
uh yes i i think i did mention before
that the council is developing its
climate change strategy
and i think it's just one of those
practical pragmatic
um you know things that we decided it
would be better to wait until that
strategy's been developed and we can see
what direction the council's going in
what what actions it intends to take and
then audit that
rather than if we were to order it
before that we'd probably be suggesting
things that the council
would be doing anyway it wouldn't
necessarily add value so that was that
was the conversation around that
but i do take the point it's an
important area
thank you and the second second question
if i may chair on page 26 again about
the affordable housing
target again we
you've also alluded to the fact that
that we are on course to deliver less
than 50
of the affordable
housing target um you've given a
moderate
uh assurance on this although
allowing 130 affordable houses per year
over the last seven years from 2014 so
we should have
910 but we've actually got 400.
how are we how do you
get the assurance that we will be able
to be on target for that
yeah i mean i think that's possibly the
converse of the argument um
we were talking about before so i think
if you actually look at the last
three years um so 1920 to what is
um projected to happen in 2122
you'll see that over those three years
the council
is expecting to deliver its targets if
you take those three years together so i
think
that's where we're seeing the
improvement um after what i agree is a
very slow start and that and that is
really what's contributed to the council
being so far behind
all right thank you chairman thank you
mr leslie you did put your hand up did
you want to come back
just ready to echo what mr riven said
around the climate
change strategy that is one of the
council's priorities uh strategy we're
coming forward
um two members to approve so it felt a
bit premature at this stage but we
didn't have the approved
uh strategy to actually undertake an
audit and have been far
more uh effective to to wait until next
year
i'm going to go to councillor hall and
then i'll come to you councillor fleming
councillor hull thank you
um mr i it came to me this week that a
lot of the
affordable housing have been sold to a
london council
is this so and if it is so do our
um local people do they are they still
able to other housing still for them
also
can i hand that over to mr swords please
good evening members
no we often have this rumor in the
district i am not aware of this current
point in time of any such situation of
any
london borough buying affordable housing
out here
on all the strategic sites we're aware
of who the housing associations are
through obviously contact with them and
with the developers
and on those strategic sites just to
reassure members that
as its new build people of the district
on the housing register in housing need
we get 100 nomination rights on first
lets of those properties
it isn't to say that a london borough
couldn't buy properties in this district
and do that as they have done in other
areas
but no i'm not aware of it and on our
strategic sites in any of the
developments i'm working with with the
housing associations
i'm not aware of any any london councils
buying buying affordable units
thank you mr swords um councillor
fleming
thank you chair um just turning to page
28
um the table table one uh it says
20 21 22 units completed and then in
brackets units expected
am i correct in thinking that units
expected is just
applicable to to this year and how how
do we derive that figure is it just sort
of plucked from the sky
or or is there you know so far we've
we've achieved half and so it's
reasonable to assume that we'll
achieve the other half in the
second part of the year thank you before
i go into mr swords
uh councillor hull can you turn your mic
off please
and council fleming thank you mr sores
do you want to answer that
um those figures that you're seeing over
you know
2021 and previous years i monitor
on my own development spreadsheet with
all the developers and housing
associations
on a regular basis with them what's
happening with those units when are they
due to be complete so i'm constantly
keeping up to date with what's coming
through
and those numbers and figures i feed
into
the section 106 officer because i
believe he also does a half-yearly
report i think back to this committee
on what's happening with all the
affordable in the district and the
figure there
we had to look at the financial year
and so obviously we're still in the
financial year until
um april march april and
obviously we've taken account there of
units so far i believed completed to
date on that figure
so we've still got stuff coming through
now um up until christmas and into the
new year we've got affordable units
coming through
is there any more questions for this now
you've all had the recommendations in
front of you
um do you agree those recommendations
by ascent or would you like to go to the
vote
thank you we move on
to item seven which is the
internal audit and statement of
assurance
2020 to 2021 found on pages 57
to 76 i would call again on mr rubins
to present this report thank you mr
rubins
thank you it's worth me coming after all
um so this is
our annual uh report annual opinions it
summarises our work for the year
um so there shouldn't be too many
surprises in here i'm going to talk to
pages 61 and 62
of your pack on this so um you'll see
overall we've given moderate assurance
that's our second highest level of
assurance
in terms of um you know where we think
you are overall
on governance risk and control and it's
the same level we gave last year
i think on the whole actually if you
look at the individual opinions
there's been an improvement since last
year we've got no limited opinions this
year
and that's good to see and i think
particularly given the circumstances of
the year with covid
and the pressures on on staff i think
that's a very positive
um conclusion there's still are some
issues obviously and you know we've
talked about the housing
uh report there was the safeguarding
report as well that we presented earlier
in the year
um so still some things to address i
would say
and you'll see on um on the themes on
page 69
uh we've tried to sort of summarize some
of the areas uh that we think the
council perhaps could look at that in
terms of
you know we think that there's some
generally good processes uh
well-designed processes but the
implementation sometimes
is not a hundred percent consistent so
there's still work to be done around
that
um but i think overall as i said i think
it's a positive report
and we also comment on the back of the
report on page
73 on the internal audit performance and
again i think
um that's gone pretty well in terms of
delivering the plan
um you know still challenges for us as
well in terms of delivering under covid
and you know we'll we'll be aiming to
for more timeliness
next year in terms of completing all the
plan earlier in the year but i think
overall
we've had good feedback on our work and
hopefully um that will be endorsed by
members but happy to take any comments
or questions
thank you before we go to that i would
like to move the recommendations
that the committee considers comments
and approves the
little one internal audit annual report
and annual statement of assurance for
2020 21
at appendix one can i have a seconder
thank you councillor none now right out
in the debate
does any members have questions
councillor heard
thank you i just want to be clear on
page spoke about
spoken about this year the current year
and previous year
it says in the current year that the
majority of audits provide substantial
assurance
and it says limited is one and then in
the second
point it says uh limited two
and then in the third one it says we did
not issue any limited insurance reports
this year
i'm just unsure as to which year
so we're referring to the year 2021 so
the year ending 31st of march 2021 and
in that year
there were no limited opinions but we
then give in brackets the figures from
1920 so the previous
year to that where there were some
limited opinions and that's where those
numbers
come from i hope that's clear
any other questions
no
you've had the recommendations in front
of you members
would you like to agree these by ascent
i'll move to a vote thank you
mr rubens thank you very much for that
um i to mate on the agenda is the
external
audit and audit planning report to march
31 you move to item
eight on the agenda found on pages 37 to
50.
no it's not random pages 77-108
mr wisdom would you like to come and
present your report
thank you mr wisdom
hey good evening good evening everyone
um
as per usual i'll assume the document is
red but i will just pull out some of the
key messages
so just a reminder that the the work
that i perform
continues to be carried out in
accordance with the code of order
practice and supporting regulations
which are published by the national
order office
the the scope of my work includes the
audit of the accounts
along with satisfying myself that the
council has made
proper arrangements for securing value
for money
there have been significant changes to
the code with respect to the value for
money requirements and these are set out
in more detail
on page 94 of the pack the materiality
level that i use has been set on a
consistent basis to that that i used in
previous years
and that then calculates at 1.2 million
pounds
it is worth mentioning it is worth
remembering though that i do report all
errors that i identify through the
course of my old in excess of 60 000
pounds so whilst my overall materiality
is high i do report to all areas over 60
000 pounds
as you would expect the pandemic has
continued to impact the order both in
terms of the risk profile
as well as the way that we conduct the
order and again there is more detail on
that on pages 88 and 89 of the pack
the significant risks that i'm going to
be focusing on this year are
management override of controls
a reminder that auditing standards
presume that there is a risk
around accounts being fraudulently
mistaken by
management around overriding of controls
so this is a significant risk for every
single audit that we have it's not
not unique to to malden
the areas that we focus in in for this
risk are the preparation of accounting
estimates
looking at inappropriate journal entries
and also transactions which have no
economic substance
the second significant risk is is a new
one this year
and it is the recognition of covert 19
related income
the reason i've included this is a
significant risk is because
as i'm sure you're well aware there are
a number of new grants with a
significant value
which are accounted for and these grants
can be accounted for in different ways
and some of them require judgment as
well as to how they're accounted for
so those are the two significant risks
but i also have
some areas of focus that i've
highlighted in
in the plan those areas of focus are the
pension liability
again i focused on this last year and in
particular i'm looking at the
assumptions that are used as part of
that the calculation of that actuarial
liability
and the second area of focus again is
will be familiar to those of you who'd
be on the committee
we'll be focusing on the valuation of
property plant and equipment
you may well recall that this was
escalated to a significant risk
last year due to the limit of errors
that we identified
however having reviewed the results of
our work and also the council's response
to our recommendations
i've downgraded that back down to an
area of focus for
for the year um there's more detail on
each of the significant understanding
areas of focus within the within the
report
i chair that's the the highlights from
the report that i was in my plan that i
was going to put out but i'm obviously
had to take questions
thank you before we take those questions
i will move the recommendations
and the recommendation of cetera in the
report is as follows recommendation one
that the external audit planning report
as shown in appendix one be considered
can i have a seconder for that
recommendation thank you councillor nunn
uh members i open the debate councillor
none
uh thank you chair and um thank you mr
uh
wisdom and i'm surprised that you're
going to focus on
pension liability um as an issue bearing
in mind that
this is a local authority and the staff
if they're in a pension scheme will be
in
local government pension scheme so it's
a
a nationally recognized scheme and any
liabilities i would have thought would
have been
uh assessed by the actuary so
what exactly will you be auditing when
it comes to that
please cindy so
so you what you say is entirely correct
but
the the outcome of everything that
you've said is that there is a
significant liability
that sits on the council's balance sheet
and that that liability is is large but
it
it's also very judgmental so there's
actuarial assumptions
um they are determined by an actuary
absolutely but they are
subject to a lot of judgment so that's
one element of
of it but the the other area that there
is judgment around is
there are there are a number of assets
that obviously reduce the overall
uh actual lot with the liability that
appears on your balance sheet
and again some of those assets are off
relatively straightforward
so they are valued gilts for example are
very
relatively straightforward but other of
those assets are actually quite
difficult to value and again there is a
significant judgment
associated with those assets so for
example if they were invested in private
equity funds so
the combination of those two elements um
there is a lot of judgment there's a lot
of estimate
and the the the result of all of that is
a
a large liability that sits in the
council's balance sheet and that's why
i have it as an area of focus
could i come back on that please check
thanks thank you for that mr wisdom
but the the presumably that when you
talk about the investment
the investment is by the scheme not by
this council
yes you're correct but the the scheme
as i say ultimately the liability does
sit on the
on the council's balance sheet and this
and the council is responsible
for that liability so yes the the
investment
decisions are made by the
by the uh the pension scheme and uh you
know
there is a pool of assets but the
results of those decisions
directly impact the council because the
the end result
is the the net liability that sits on
your balance sheet so
yeah so sorry just in conclusion then so
so you're assessing the risk
but it's not a controllable risk
uh it's i would agree with you it's not
directly controllable by yourself
no but but it is still it does
ultimately fall to you as a counselor is
ultimately your responsibility to ensure
that the number is correct because it is
in your accounts and you're signing off
that those accounts
are correct okay thank you mr wizard
thank you chair thank you
mr leslie wants to come in on that
probably just to make clear as well that
uh quite rightly the uh pension fund is
administrated by essex county council uh
they look after that
for the district authorities um and they
will be using their actors
um to get the figures which they will
then uh provide to us
uh and they have those figures audited
um as well
so it's those figures from essex county
council's actuaries um
which we use and we don't want to see
administrator the schema
councillor stevens thank you chair
my questions about the fees that are
outlined on page 106
um seems to have gone up from 54.8 to
88.6 000
in a year it does say something about a
scale fee
increase but as a new counsellor i'm not
too sure what that means could you
explain that for us please
thank you
um yes so um in terms of the
the feeds that we've put in there again
as
a new council we've had we've had um a
number of discussions around
um fees and the the the fee that's in
there is the proposed fee from me which
still has to be approved by
psaa so the the scale fee is the
is the base fee that is set by psaa and
anything that is above that scale fee
then has to be
approved by pso well it has to be
approved by the council and psaa so
again i'm
i'm happy to to provide further detail
if
needed in terms of the historical um
position but as i say that
there was a paper that has come to
previous committees which set out the
basis for that fee which
um that the council has then asked for
uh psa's input on
uh and psa are in the process of
assessing that and then we'll come back
with the decision on that as well
i'll go to mr leslie so he might be able
to clarify some
thank you so yes we've held a number of
discussions um
around this and we have circulated a
briefing paper to the committee
um but i'm not sure whether you were on
the committee at that time
because it's even so i'm happy to
circulate i think they'll be beneficial
to perhaps do that round to the
new committee um which perhaps would
answer some of the questions but yes
we've been engaged
uh with the external tools for quite a
while around those fees
the scale fees were set several years
ago
um now and they uh subject to
fee variations and i think mr wisdom has
explained that due to the nature
and the increases in auditor
requirements which have been substantial
over recent times we've seen a lot of
increase
in terms of audit fees around that
side of it the fee has been reduced
through initial discussions
and what will happen now with the fee as
once the audience concluded
um the auditors will submit that to the
the body the psaa
who will review those fees uh on behalf
and they
effectively give the judgment around
that if they're if they feel they're
fair and they have the final say
they will contact us as well within that
process so we can put our side across
and part of the work they do as a large
body look after
i think all of the councils audits as
well they
will do benchmarking and from time to
time they could even look at
uh some of the work that the auditors
haven't taken and have a look at that
to do that so that's where their skills
expertise and benchmarking ability
come in but until the audit is completed
that process can't
take place councillor heard
so so um mrs wright when he describes
the fact that the audit
uh of um essex county council uh happens
but
essex county council represents a number
of
different bodies that you know the staff
that are employed by a number of
different councils is not just malden
what they what the actually does is
they they work out on mold and specific
bit of the essex that the total pot is
and then they send those figures across
to malden
so the numbers that are audited by essex
pension scheme are the whole of the
pension scheme
so obviously those incorporate more than
but they will order to a much
larger and much greater materiality
because they're looking at the whole
thing
whereas what i'm interested in is the
bit that's been carved out and is that
bit that's been carved out
is that correct and is the liability
that's ultimately
resting that is the liability that
management are recording or counseling
officers are
recording in the back in the accounts is
that the right amount for
mulder and so that's the bit that i'm
auditing
is there any other questions counseling
um
fleming thank you jen
i just wanted to go to page 103 appendix
2
uncorrected miss statements um i just
wanted
an explanation for both uh
items there overstatement of council
office valuation
and the goodwin judgment impact pensions
thank you mr leslie
yeah thank you thank you yes so those
were um the ones from last year's
account the valuation of the office's
valuations by the nature uh are
subjective and it's
below materiality so there's no
requirement to change um
those uh from perspective i could just
check is the question why weren't they
just um adjusted for or why did they
occur sorry
yeah just interested to to know how they
occurred
thank you okay uh so in terms of the
evaluation of the office um it relates
to um i
believe the overflow car park there so
essentially it was a bit of a double
count
in the valuations and it included the
car park twice i think that was the main
issue around that
and in terms of the mcleod judgment that
again relates to the pension
scheme so late in the day we had an
adjustment
to the original pension value but
because obviously the size of the scheme
and the fact that
lastly an estimate we didn't adjust for
that when we had
subsequent information from the
actuaries around the impact of the
mcleod judgment to the pension fund
liability
is there any other questions for mr
wisdom or mr leslie no you have the
recommendations before you
are members happy to accept those by
ascent or move to a vote
thank you thank you mr wisdom for
that presentation item 10 on the agenda
is any other business that the chairman
decides
is uh urgent i have none
so item 11 on the
agenda is closure of the minutes thank
you members thank you for your
contributions this evening
i draw the meeting to a close at 10
past eight as member as the meeting is
now closed members are advised not to
enter into any further discussion on
this
you